[Música]
la ahora llamada cárcel de los
presidentes tiene un nuevo inquilino
estamos hablando del penal del
barbadillo en Lima la capital peruana a
donde llegó el expresidente Alejandro
Toledo después de haber sido extraditado
desde Estados Unidos en esta misma
institución están recluidos también
Pedro castillo y Alberto fujimori dos ex
mandatarios peruanos Pero por qué vuelve
a saltar a la escena pública el
expresidente Alejandro Toledo pues Les
explico a continuación Alejandro Toledo
gobernó Perú entre los años 2001 y 2006
y fue extraditado como ya les decía
desde Estados Unidos a su país natal
para responder ante la justicia por
varios cargos en su contra siendo este
hecho de la extradición algo inédito en
la historia política peruana reciente a
Toledo lo acusan de haber recibido cerca
de 35 millones de dólares para que
beneficiara la licitación de una empresa
para adjudicar la construcción de la
ruta interoceánica que es una vía que un
a Brasil con Perú permite unir el Océano
Atlántico con el Pacífico y viceversa
todo esto en el marco del llamado caso
odebrecht justamente Esa fue la empresa
beneficiada que como ustedes saben
estableció un enorme sistema de pago de
sobornos y de favores a diferentes
políticos en diferentes países de la
región a cambio de ser adjudicadas estas
enormes obras de infraestructura en Perú
la investigación también afectó al ex
fallecido presidente Alan García al
expresidente ollanta humala y también ha
salpicado en cierta forma a la ex
candidata presidencial keiko fujimori la
justicia peruana tiene este caso abierto
en relación a la constructora odebrech
desde el año 2017 a Toledo se le acusa
de corrupción y también la fiscalía de
Perú lo tiene en otro caso Algo similar
en un caso llamado como ecotema allí lo
acusan es de lavado de dinero es decir
son dos investigaciones que confluyen en
unos puntos en común que vamos a más
adelante a lo largo del programa la
fiscalía peruana Entonces ha pedido
penas de veinte años y seis meses de
cárcel por la concesión de los tramos 2
y 3 de esta ruta interoceánica o dos y
cuatro mejor y adicionalmente otros 35
años por el último tramo de esta vía
interoceánica y también 16 años y 8
meses por el caso ecoteva de ser hallado
culpable Toledo entonces pasaría
prácticamente el resto de su vida en una
prisión en la Ciudad de Lima que sigue
entonces así las cosas para el
expresidente Toledo que sigue para este
exmandatario peruano Qué significa para
el caso odebrecht la extradición de
Toledo que repercusión tiene este caso a
nivel político para Perú un país que ya
tiene varios problemas y antecedentes de
inestabilidad política como este avance
entonces comienza con este avance Mejor
dicho esto digamos que representa un
intento de la justicia peruana y de de
ese país de tratar de cerrar este
complicado episodio de La historia de
odebrecht que como decimos no afectó
solamente a Perú sino también a otros
países de la región vamos entonces a
comenzar el programa y paso entonces a
presentarles a las personas que hemos
convocado invitado para hablar y
analizar este tema está con nosotros
Elizabeth sea ella es directora del
instituto de derechos humanos y
desarrollo usmp ella se encuentra desde
la Ciudad de Lima la capital peruana y
desde esta misma ciudad se conecta José
Alejandro Godoy él es politólogo y
docente universitario nuestros
televidentes ustedes ya lo saben hacen
parte de este debate pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
Facebook y en instagram nos encuentran
como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f-24 todo junto y a mí me
encuentran en Twitter como arroba
santilogo no olviden también que todos
los contenidos de este programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la palabra a
Elizabeth en la Ciudad de Lima Elizabeth
Gracias por estar con nosotros aquí en
el debate de France 24 y ya que está en
Perú el expresidente Alejandro Toledo
que sigue para él entonces en el marco
de este caso en esta investigación por
parte de la justicia peruana
Bueno sí en este momento ya el señor
Toledo ha sido conducido como bien
dijiste al penal barbadillo no y bueno
ahora lo que sigue de acuerdo a lo que
es el procedimiento antes de lo que es
la esta audiencia oral tiene que seguir
este juicio oral es una audiencia que se
llama control de acusación donde ya la
defensa va a tener la oportunidad de dar
sustentos técnicos a fin de poder
cuestionar los tipos penales que están
planteando no respecto a este caso de la
erosión ética que es justamente por el
cual el señor Toledo lo tenemos aquí no
ha sido extraditado y para que de esta
manera un poco el proceso antes de pasar
a cuestionar este debidamente saneado no
y poder este darle la oportunidad
también a la defensa técnica para que
pueda plantear Cuáles son esos
cuestionamientos que tiene no a los
delitos invocados
la opinión de Elizabeth desde la Ciudad
de Lima y allí También en la capital
peruana está Alejandro nuestro siguiente
invitado Alejandro Gracias por estar con
nosotros Bienvenido al programa y su
opinión que sigue entonces para este
caso para el expresidente Toledo
ya en el marco del avance que ha dado la
justicia peruana al pedirlo en
extradición a Estados Unidos
Bueno lo que siguen son dos cosas Una ya
lo comentó ya lo comentó la doctora sea
es todo el proceso legal en lo que se
refiere al caso por el cual el señor
Toledo ha sido extraditado qué tiene que
ver indudablemente con la recetación de
fondos de dinero por parte de la empresa
odebrecht Aparentemente también por
otras empresas brasileñas pero lo
segundo que hay que mencionar es que
estaría pendiente para ampliar la
extradición del caso de coteba que como
ustedes han mencionado muy bien es un
caso eh que está conexo a este no el
caso de coteba lo que implica es el
lavado de activos
provenientes precisamente de este de
estos sobornos presuntamente otorgados
por odebrecht a través de la compra de
un conjunto de bienes inmuebles en Perú
a través de una empresa Oxford
constituida en Costa Rica por allegados
al expresidente tolero tanto
como exfuncionarios del gobierno del
expresidente entonces queda pendiente
eso hay que mencionar además que el
expresidente Toledo no tiene en este
momento casi ningún respaldo político su
partido no tiene inscripción política y
más allá de algunas este personas que el
día de ayer
hicieron unas muy pequeñas y realidades
manifestaciones a su favor el señor
Toledo básicamente está solo aislado
políticamente y no va a tener la
posibilidad de utilizar otro tipo de
recursos más allá de los legales para
poder afrontar esa situación que como
bien ya se ha registrado en la
introducción del programa podría
llevarlo a una pena depresión que dada
la edad del expresidente podría ser Casi
casi como una suerte de cadena perpetua
haciendo referencia a eso Alejandro
continuó con usted para hacer la ronda
la inversa Toledo dijo en Estados Unidos
pocos minutos antes de embarcarse rumbo
hacia Perú dijo Le pido la justicia
peruana que no me mate en la cárcel
déjeme luchar con argumentos aquí que
podemos inferir de lo que decía el
expresidente se refería a cierta forma a
pedir garantías en el marco de la
justicia peruana o justamente a Ese
temor de recibir una pena lo
suficientemente larga Que prácticamente
lo condena a estar el resto de su vida
en prisión
de un lado lo que lo que él pide es que
el proceso se lleve a cabo del modo más
rápido más rápido posible no cosa que
probablemente en el caso de él sí se dé
no eh los otros justiciables en Perú
este
pueden tener dilaciones de procesos
durante años pero cuando se trata de
procesos como este en el cual están
involucrados muy altas autoridades
normalmente tanto por la atención
mediática como por la propia importancia
del caso
en este tipo de procesos el poder
judicial del Ministerio Público
tradicionalmente son mucho más rápidos y
por tanto es muy probable que antes de
fin de año los juicios que tiene
pendiente el el expresidente Toledo ya
arranque con su presencia y finalmente
él pueda finalmente
tener probablemente en el plazo de un
año o un año y medio una sentencia este
por lo menos de primera instancia y
luego una confirmación de la misma ante
la ante la Corte Suprema no hay que
indicar que el expresidente Toledo ya no
tiene derecho a un beneficio de ante
juicio político dado el tiempo que ha
transcurrido desde su este salida del
poder en el año 2006 hasta el día de hoy
Elizabeth y cuál es su opinión en torno
a esta frase que citaba yo del
expresidente Toledo y le prolongó y la
extiendo un poco más la pregunta si se
puede confiar en la justicia peruana en
este momento vemos a un país que ha
tenido muchísimos altibajos políticos en
los últimos años se puede confiar en la
separación de poderes en Perú se puede
confiar en la justicia peruana en este
caso y qué opinión tiene esta frase del
expresidente
Bueno indudablemente hay que recordar
que este proceso de extradición tiene
Data desde el 2017 en el que en un
magistrado solicita el juez carhuancho
solicita una prisión preventiva para el
señor Toledo en torno justamente a este
caso de odebrecht y en los
cuestionamientos que existían sobre la
interoceánica y ha sido un proceso
bastante largo ha sido un proceso que en
Estados Unidos no se han cumplido
digamos todos los estadios inclusive
haciendo eh
caso digamos considerando aquellos
pedidos de la defensa técnica de Toledo
en razón a las garantías que el la
justicia peruana brindaba para su
extradición y posterior procesamiento
aquí en suelo peruano no la justicia
estadounidense ha sido lo
suficientemente cautelosa para que a
partir del momento de la solicitud que
hace la Corte Suprema no vía cancillería
pueda
estudiar Si es que la justicia peruana
ofrece estas garantías que nosotros de
por sí ya desde la Constitución incluso
tenemos la obligación de brindar y creo
que se está haciendo porque el día que
él ha pisado suelo peruano en este
control esta primera audiencia de
control de identidad señor Toledo se le
ha evaluado su salud por qué lo que él
anuncia Es que le está mal de salud y
que no podría enfrentar a la justicia
Porque no confía en la justicia y piensa
que lo van a someter Pues a algún tipo
de trato humano tortura o que no se va a
respetar el debido proceso pero como
también te digo esto ya ha sido ha
pasado por la debida valoración y
evaluación tras la justicia americana y
de ser así Es por eso que ha procedido
la extradición y hoy en día Ya lo
tenemos aquí por lo tanto yo creo que
esta frase del señor Toledo es una es un
intento más de tratar de saber la
atención de su evidente responsabilidad
porque no hay que olvidar que este caso
tiene sobre todo el caso lavado de
activos siendo un fuerte sustento en las
declaraciones tanto de barata Como de
maiman que ha sido una persona
colaboradora directa del señor Toledo y
tiene suficiente sustento técnico legal
como para que el señor rinda no a la
justicia peruana las cuentas que debe
con las garantías a su salud y a su
seguridad Elizabeth justamente en ruta
usted la siguiente pregunta que tenía
lista para hacerle y Es sobre estos dos
personajes clave hay varios en
diferentes digamos extensión de este
caso pero puntuales para este escenario
de la investigación es este empresario
peruano israelí Joseph maiman y barata
que era justamente un funcionario de
odebrecht en Perú qué tan claves fueron
estos dos actores para llegar a este
escenario en el que estamos viendo donde
el expresidente ha sido extraditado a a
suelo peruano
Claro en realidad
ha sido bastante importante la
declaración sobre todo el señor maiman
porque él ha sido un colaborador directo
amigo del señor Toledo y ha declarado
acogiéndose a la colaboración eficaz que
efectivamente el recibió dinero algo de
25 millones de dólares no
de la empresa odebrecht por el contrato
interoceánica atole para Toledo ahora el
tema aquí es que hay que probar la
procedencia del dinero no Y si Toledo
sabía la presencia del dinero que de
acuerdo a nuestro marco judicial peruano
nuestro marco penal pues este tiene que
ser dinero ilícito no de activos el tema
de narcoterrorismo y esto ya tiene que
ser probado dentro de la instancia
judicial no Pero existe Sí estas estas
dos declaraciones con acogimiento a esta
figura de colaborador eficaz que la
justicia peruana ha tomado en cuenta
justamente para que pueda el señor
Toledo no pronunciarse respecto a estas
acusaciones pero en la vía judicial como
debe de ser claro Alejandro su opinión
sobre estas dos fichas clave muchas
personas y analistas han dicho que aquí
prácticamente hubo una especie como de
traición de un amigo por parte de Joseph
myman que declaró dio esta versión de
los hechos y
esta persona ya pues falleció hace un
par de años y ya no puede volver a
presentarse ante la justicia ha dado un
requerimiento pero dejó esta versión y
ha sido tomada en cuenta y es parte de
esa investigación clave que
prácticamente Deja a la defensa del
expresidente Toledo sin Con qué
defenderse de manera muy efectiva cómo
lo ve usted
claro la declaración del ya fallecido
empresario Joseph bayman es clave en
todo este caso porque no solamente tiene
un relato consistente de los hechos sino
que ha dado detalles no tuvo determinado
tipo de reuniones con el señor Toledo y
con el señor barata en Brasil en el año
2004 eh Allí se pusieron de acuerdo con
el monto inicial entre asuntos soborno
luego el señor maiman ha dado cuenta de
reuniones que él ha tenido con el señor
barata para ponerse de acuerdo en los
términos de digamos la coartada para
recibir este este dinero este ilegal y
luego el Señor maiman
por por por razones de querer dejar sus
negocios este tranquilos frente a una
este posibilidad una enfermedad terminal
que él tenía
decidió contar todo esto Pero además
decidió contar toda la ruta del dinero
no es decir de cómo llega el dinero de
él a él Perdón desde odebrech Y luego
cómo ese dinero se transforma a través
de un conjunto de empresas offshore para
que luego puedan hacer la decisión de
las casas e inmuebles que el señor
Toledo tramitó a través de esta empresa
short ecoteva pero también el pago de
hipotecas sobre otros inmuebles que el
señor Toledo tenía ya este a su
disposición en Lima y en punta sangre Un
conocido a diario del Norte del país
donde el el ex mandatario acostumbraba
vería Incluso en tiempos en los que era
presidente del Perú Entonces
el testimonio del señor
barata es el que abre la investigación
pero el testimonio del señor mayman que
es un amigo personal o fue un amigo
personal el señor www durante poco más
de 40 años es el que prácticamente
confirma una versión que deja como ya lo
ha mencionado sin ningún sustento a la
defensa del expresidente
Alejandro falta otro personaje
importante aquí por analizar ya hemos
visto el contexto los cargos estamos
viendo los actores y tengo que sumar a
esa lista la esposa del expresidente
Toledo el de encarp que se encuentra en
Estados Unidos es una ciudadana que
tiene ciudadanía belga e israelí por ser
de descendencia judía y es también una
ficha clave que podría entrar a cambiar
un poco el escenario qué tan implicada
está ella en este caso puede llegar a
ser requerida por parte de la justicia
peruana o temen allí en Perú que ya
pueda por ejemplo irse de Estados Unidos
a Bélgica a un país que no tiene
convenios de extradición con Perú no
podría ser enviada a territorio peruano
y lo mismo pasa con Israel bueno el
problema justamente
no extraditan los nacionales y además
el Perú dado de que a la señora Kart se
le va a entregar el
ya la el extradición de su esposo el
pasaporte que ya que ya tenía y que
estaba retenido si es que no se acelera
ninguna medida rápida por parte de este
el poder judicial peruano para que el
poder judicial estadounidense pueda de
alguna u otra manera retenerla en el
territorio de los Estados Unidos es muy
probable que exista un riesgo
relativamente alto de que la señora
Carmen no puede hacer procesada por
estos eventos y el efecto es una pieza
clave porque la madre de la señora Kart
es este la persona que prestó su nombre
para la adquisición de estos inmuebles a
través de esta empresa usuaria llamada
llamada
de que se trata una de una sociedad
conyugal en este caso iba a ser también
beneficiaria directa de el dinero que el
señor Toledo era o estaba hoy día
manejando de forma irregular no Y además
ella también tenía un contacto directo
con el señor por tanto tenemos aquí un
conjunto de elementos que han hecho que
la justicia peruana la tenga ahí en
calidad investigada y que exista también
la posibilidad de poder pedir su
extradición desde los desde los Estados
Unidos pero si no hay una medida
inmediata de este impedimento de salida
del país
puede ser altamente probable que la
señal la carta que busque la acción de
la justicia Elizabeth su opinión sobre
este caso particular de la esposa de la
expresidente y también hablemos de la
defensa hasta ahora lo único que han
dicho es que se trató de un préstamo que
no era dinero que llegara a través de
flujos diferentes a los que ellos han
explicado que más ha dicho la defensa
del expresidente y que argumentos puede
tener bajo la manga para tratar de
defender la posición del expresidente
Toledo
bueno con respecto a la señora
claro la señora Elián parece que en este
momento También estaría siendo
comprendida por la fiscalía en este caso
de conteo y lavado de activos para que
pueda venir también extraditada al Perú
y hay un peligro porque a ella le acaban
de dar el pasaporte no hay un peligro de
fuga inminente con la señora quien ya en
anterior oportunidad en años anteriores
ella se presentó aquí en el congreso de
la república para eh dar cuentas sobre
toda la comisión que estaba viendo estos
casos no
Y definitivamente pues ella cuestionó en
todo momento que las hipotecas de estos
inmuebles no habían sido pagados dinero
de coteba no y que en ningún momento
pues ha habido ni tampoco uso de las
tarjetas de crédito al nombre de la
señora y que ella tampoco está implicada
en estas transacciones pero todo esto
tiene que ser definitivamente dilucidado
dentro de lo que es el proceso no un
proceso judicial aquí en el Perú porque
ese es el caso en el cual también
ella siendo comprendida por el
Ministerio Público no solamente en
Alejandro Toledo Y definitivamente pues
tiene que venir al Perú también no se
entiende que la ampliación de la
extradición también la comprendería a
ella y eso sería Pues dentro a la
brevedad en el menor tiempo posible no
la defensa técnica todavía respecto al
caso de liancard no se ha pronunciado al
respecto qué es lo que hacer pero desde
ya al negar toda responsabilidad
respecto a Alejandro Toledo en en estos
casos de colusión tráfico de influencias
también estarían negando En consecuencia
cuál eh su inclusión en el delito de
lavado de activos y por lo tanto también
se podría ver que estaría también
tratando de deslindar no la
participación de la señora Carmen
Elizabeth
llama mucho la atención que Perú haya
avanzado en esta investigación a lo
largo de todos estos años si comparamos
a Perú con otros países de la región
Como por ejemplo Colombia en donde el
mismo escándalo odebrecht no llegó a
ningún Puerto no hay un funcionario o
expresidente que esté pagando alguna
condena por estos casos de soborno en
Brasil Lula de Silva fue a la cárcel
volvió a salir hoy en día es el
presidente de Brasil nuevamente Qué
significa para para Perú avanzar en este
caso en estas investigaciones en estas
acusaciones
para un país con tantos altibajos
políticos e inestabilidad
Sí definitivamente el impacto que está
teniendo en mi país el caso odebrecht y
El Avance que tiene la
el poder judicial la justicia no
es bastante importante sobre todo en vía
Pues un mensaje poderoso creo yo también
en temas de de una política que debe de
estar libre de todo trazo de corrupción
yo creo que aquí el mensaje no solamente
es para la ciudadanía que creo que en
algo está viendo en este avance algo de
Justicia porque no olvidemos que detrás
de los delitos de corrupción existe
también vulneración de Derechos Humanos
no de aquellas personas que son privadas
justamente de esta presencia del estado
de la asistencia en en servicio de salud
de servicios públicos porque este dinero
está siendo destinado no a actos de
corrupción sobre todo por las instancias
de decisión En los niveles de gobierno
los diferentes niveles de gobierno
entonces esa es su primer mensaje a la
ciudadanía pero también a la política yo
creo que las autoridades
respecto a las autoridades electorales
también de Cómo debemos de ver estos
esta esta importancia que tiene el
perfil ético en la función pública no
así sean cargos de elección o cargos de
confianza definitivamente no podemos
dejar de lado que una persona que va a
tener a su cargo el destino de la nación
no puede estar pues impulso en este tipo
de
digamos en este tipo de actos no
delictivos y hoy en día a nivel político
también aquí en el Perú se está viendo
pues por ejemplo el caso del señor
Castillo que también en este momento
está en prisión preventiva y donde
también vemos que la fiscalía está
actuando de una manera conforme a ley no
y respetando el debido proceso pero
siempre teniendo a aclarar una serie de
malos manejos que han habido
también en su gestión Entonces yo creo
que hay que tomar en cuenta hay que
tomarlo como un mensaje muy positivo no
y del que tenemos que aprender todos
Alejandro su opinión sobre lo que
significa políticamente este caso para
para Perú y para la justicia de este
país su opinión
bueno tenemos por tercera vez
aún el presidente preso en el Perú el
señor fujimori ha sido sentenciado tanto
por graves violaciones a los Derechos
Humanos como por sucesos de corrupción
el señor Castillo viene siendo procesado
como ya se ha dicho con todas las
garantías tanto por su intento de golpe
de estado como por una serie de sucesos
que también lo involucran en presuntos
actos de corrupción no entonces el caso
del señor Toledo va a ser probablemente
ejemplar no es muy probable que otros
este ex mandatarios que puedan estar
también eh dispuestos a a frotar la
acción de la justicia de hecho en este
momento El Señor villantomaya está este
materia de un juicio oral el
expresidente Pedro Pablo y el
expresidente Martín vizcarra son materia
de investigación entonces en general
nuestros últimos mandatarios de 199
hasta aquí han este tenido Clara y
notoriamente
un conjunto de cuestiones por las cuales
responder quizás la lección más
importante en términos comparados en
América Latina es que a diferencia de lo
que ocurre en otros países
estas personas no solamente son
procesadas sino que como en el caso del
señor fujimori son sentenciadas no y en
todos los casos se cumplen con las
reglas básicas debido proceso es decir
estamos hablando de un tipo de proceso
distinto al que se puede tener en otras
partes de América Latina donde
probablemente la justicia sea mucho más
politizada o donde las garantías debido
proceso no sean respetadas entonces creo
que esto es una elección importante para
la región que es una región en donde
hemos tenido graves casos de
vulneraciones a los derechos
fundamentales y graves casos de
corrupción que han este terminado de la
impunidad pero parece que el caso de
Perú es precisamente la excepción a la
regla Alejandro una declaración de myman
llevó prácticamente a que a lo largo de
los años se determinará esta extradición
hacia territorio peruano del
expresidente Toledo
él tendrá también que rendir algún tipo
de declaración y rendir cuentas ante la
justicia estamos ante la punta del
iceberg de este caso más funcionarios de
presidencias anteriores o funcionarios
de gobiernos anteriores podrían estar
implicados y estarían enfrentando
también acusaciones y a la justicia
peruana o esto se quedará en ese nivel
de mandatarios
no hay varios varios otros casos que
tienen que ver con con el proceso
odebrech o lo que se ha llamado del caso
el caso de la bajato a partir de lo de
lo visto en Brasil y de hecho es muy
probable que el caso en Perú avance
mucho más rápido de lo que de lo que ha
ocurrido de lo que ha ocurrido en Brasil
y probablemente con mayores tendencias
no tenemos eh el caso de el expresidente
humala tenemos el caso del expresidente
cuchinski si bien el expresidente García
falleció en las circunstancias que ya se
conocen hay pendiente un proceso de
pérdida de dominio de sus bienes si es
que se llegará a comprobar que fueron en
algunos casos producto de la corrupción
hay funcionarios del gobierno del
expresidente García que también vienen
siendo procesados tenemos a la
exalcaldesa de Lima Susana villarán que
proviene de la fila de la izquierda
también procesada por el caso odebrech
tenemos a la ex este candidata
presidencial también procesada por el
caso odebry por este recepción regular
de fondos de campaña no Entonces tenemos
un conjunto de personas que pertenecen a
distintos lados del espectro político de
nuestra clase política en el Perú que
están siendo sometidos a la acción de la
justicia en muchos casos la el
pronóstico es que hayan eh condenas
bastantes severas En estos casos
Entonces estamos ante el inicio de un
conjunto de procesos que deberían
comenzar entrar este año a fase juicio
oral y finalmente probablemente el
próximo año o en el año 2025 concluir ya
con sentencias declaras y definidos
Elizabeth este caso de odebrecht en
diferentes países de América Latina dejó
en evidencia algo que Es evidente y que
todos conocemos y es el funcionamiento
de la corrupción como un eje transversal
de los funcionamientos de los diferentes
estados en América Latina lo que llama
la atención en el caso peruano es que
Tal parece que esto no era ni de
izquierdas ni de derechas la corrupción
y los sobornos de odebrecht como decía
Alejandro permeó todo el espectro
político peruano Cómo se puede evaluar y
el grado de corrupción Perú en este
momento Durante este momento de
transición si se le puede llamar así
transición política que está tratando de
dar el país para terminar con esta
crisis política cuando todo el espectro
político está permeado por la corrupción
Sí bueno la corrupción a mi país le
cuesta alrededor de treinta millones de
soles no
Y eso anual y eso realmente es algo que
nos llama poderosamente la atención
porque si bien es cierto existen como
bien Se ha dicho
diferentes
expresidentes de nuestro país que hoy en
día están rindiendo cuentas a la
justicia pero también existen junto con
ellos ministros de estado y otros
funcionarios de las distintas carteras
que los acompañaron y que de alguna u
otra manera también están siendo
cuestionados en estas contrataciones
ilícitas no en estos actos sumamente
cuestionables a cualquier funcionario
público que tenga cargo de decisión este
esta cuota de poder que muchas veces es
ejercida no no para beneficiar a los
ciudadanos sino para beneficiarse ellos
mismos Entonces definitivamente
este este mensaje poderoso que nos envía
esta situación que hoy en día estamos
pasando con el señor Toledo no
definitivamente nos Llama a nosotros a
reflexionar respecto a que hay que
comenzar a establecer yo creo candados a
nivel político pero también a nivel
funcional ya dentro de la gestión
pública candados fuertes y preventivos
respecto al tema de la corrupción porque
nosotros somos un país que
lamentablemente no solamente tiene estos
estos presidentes O expresidentes sino
también tenemos gobernadores regionales
que están siendo cuestionados por
corrupción candidatos en su momento a
gobierno regional que también han tenido
casos procesos judiciales sin sentencia
pero que han podido no inclusive muchos
de ellos tener un lugar hoy en día
nuevamente en el gobierno y se van
reciclando y eso es muy muy peligroso
para nosotros Porque somos un país que
en este momento También estamos
combatiendo todavía los rezados de la
pandemia estos rezagos económicos y
sociales y definitivamente esto ataca a
las poblaciones más vulnerables de mi
país que lo que necesitan es justamente
una gestión transparente y responsable
eso también eso también es paradójico
para para muchos países que la justicia
le falta dientes para para poder
llevar a cabo estas investigaciones en
torno a la corrupción y poder empezar
por lo menos a poner sobre la mesa los
casos y las investigaciones para que
avancen para finalizar quiero hablar de
algo muy paradójico Y es que pues este
caso ha sido muy sonado no solo en Perú
sino en América Latina pero lo
paradójico Es que la ruta interoceánica
está prácticamente terminada hoy en día
es posible que cargas desde el puerto de
Río de Janeiro y de la Ciudad de Santos
que es el puerto que sirve a la ciudad
de San Pablo puedan llegar por tierra
por menos sé que está construido la
carretera hasta la ciudad de Puerto
Maldonado en el este de Perú no sé ya
las condiciones para cruzar la La
cordillera desde Puerto Maldonado hasta
las costas peruanas para conectar con el
Pacífico en qué condiciones estén pero
la ruta interoceánica existe está hecha
pese a todo este caso de corrupción pero
se ha visto beneficiado con esta obra
que permite unir al gigante de Brasil
con Perú comienzo La Ronda de la inversa
Alejandro muy puntual por favor porque
me quedan pocos minutos
en general es una hora que sí tiene un
cierto tránsito no el esperado no pero
también ha sido criticada sobre todo por
algunos este activistas este
ambientalistas por los efectos que puede
o en los datos
o por ser una vía también de tráfico de
madera ilegal u otro tipo de este
economías cereales no la carretera
interoceánica sin duda alguna es una
obra que puede permitir un intercambio
fluido de bienes pero también puede
tener esos efectos este
contraproducentes en general
ya un par de minutos para finales
Elizabeth las conclusiones lo que viene
para este caso lo que viene para Perú y
lo que viene para el ex presidente de
Toledo como conclusión para el cierre
del programa adelante
Sí bueno lo que viene como bien decíamos
es la audiencia del juicio oral donde se
espera pues ya tener digamos todos los
elementos de juicio necesarios para que
se pueda armar el caso y pedir con
solidez ya ahora sí de manera inmediata
una prisión preventiva de repente una
ampliación de la prisión preventiva y
comenzar ya las investigaciones que nos
lleven realmente a esta ruta del dinero
para establecer laitos sobre todo
establecer también la responsabilidad o
el conocimiento por parte del señor
Toledo no de la de estos casos en los
cuales se dice y se sustenta de una
manera muy sólida que él ya lo tiene la
el Ministerio Público su participación
su incursión no en este tipo de delitos
y espero realmente por el bien de mi
país que el proceso no sea largo porque
también hemos visto que en este caso
oceánica perdón el caso de odebrecht los
procesos son largos y a las finales no
hay justicia no son son en cuanto a
prisiones preventivas Pero al final no
sería una sentencia firme y se liberan a
estas personas no Espero que eso no en
el caso del señor y Alejandro su
conclusión para el cierre del programa
adelante
se trata de un proceso muy importante no
solamente para la justicia peruana sino
también para la justicia en América
Latina nuevamente estamos hablando de un
expresidente que
está haciendo procesado por graves
eventos de corrupción como ya lo
mencionábamos Perú es el país que
más avanzado en las investigaciones
sobre el caso de lavato probablemente
sea el país que más Avance en términos
de juicios Yo también espero que esta
etapa de los huesos solares sea lo más
pronta posible para evitar efectivamente
ventilaciones Y a mayores en este tipo
de procesos y que finalmente podamos
concluir con no solamente justicia sino
también claramente una reparación al
Estado peruano por el área causado pues
continuaremos haciéndole seguimiento a
este caso para ver en qué termina esta
investigación contra el expresidente
Alejandro Toledo Elizabeth Alejandro en
la Ciudad de Lima les agradezco por
haber estado con nosotros a ustedes
Muchas gracias por la sintonía En nombre
del equipo técnico Les agradecemos haber
estado con nosotros la producción del
programa estuvo a cargo de Andrés doncel
y la producción de invitados estuvo a
cargo de Tania Herrera ustedes pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
sigan con nosotros
[Música]